[Music]
just cuz you're a single parent doesn't
mean you don't want to find love more
than anybody else you know you were
saying earlier that you got a lot of
backlash for going on the show kind of
talk about that misconception and set
the record straight
yeah so I think it's hard when I went on
The Bachelor first of all I got some
backlash for it in the first place and
then also they went on paradise again I
got even more but I'm with my kids all
the time you know people see me on the
show so in their minds like that's my
life and that's what I'm doing but in
real life I'm with my kids like a
majority at the time if you know all
over on Instagram I know that this is a
kid she is literally always with her
kids do you feel like you have to
respond to them on social media like
anyone who does give you any sort of
backlash I've kind of developed some
tough skin I think for the past couple
years but I think the one thing that
bothers me more than anything is the mom
shaming it drives me crazy I hate it
what's the hardest I guess comment that
you that you get well I think something
that just bothers me is um like I'm
divorced so my kids go with their dad
every other weekend and on those
weekends it's like I don't have my kids
either way I'm not gonna see them so I
could either choose to sit at home and
clean or sometimes I choose to like go
hang out with my friends or like go on a
little mini trip or whatever I decide to
do and I think I get a lot of hate and
backlash for that and people are always
wondering when I could deal with and I
think people just forget like there's
plenty of single parents out there that
have split custody and I'm not gonna be
with them either way so I think that's
something that's kind of frustrating and
I always trying to set the record
straight with people but I think I've
just come to a conclusion that people
are gonna say stuff no matter what so
you can't win you can't win either way
yeah you really can't